good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is Pinocchio he and a professor at
the department of economics here at
Columbia and it's my privilege to open
tonight's session so for those of you
who are not familiar with Columbia let
me remind you that this is the eugene
sheffer distinguished lecture eugene
sheffer used to be the director of the
mezzo font size for for 25 years and the
Shepherd family and the other series of
lecture that enables columbia and amazon
says to invite public figures scholars
and people involved in policy and first
of all I would like to thank the three
sponsors for this evening event namely
the missile forces of colombia the
program for economic research which is
part of the account department and also
the Jerome H is an Institute for
International Business which is part of
the of the business comb as you know our
speaker tonight is jag de la Sierra and
he will be introduced by my friend and
colleague Mike Whitford I will not
introduce Mike just because it I don't
think it needs an introduction in this
world let me just remind you one thing
mark mike is considered as one of the
leading it not the leading specialists
of central banking in academia those
days and in particular he wrote a very
important book that that was published a
couple of years ago and and which was
distinguished by the deutsche bank prize
which is a very prestigious recognition
so I give the floor to Mike
Thanks as you all know the global
financial crisis has presented many
important challenges to the institutions
that are responsible for making
decisions about economic policy and some
of these challenges have to do with the
immediate situation and how it's
possible to contain or correct the
immediate consequences of the crisis
itself but there's another set of
important questions which may in fact be
with us even longer which is the
question of whether the way in which
economic policy decisions are made
should be changed in order to reduce the
risk of a similar crisis happening again
in the future and one of the important
sets of questions in that regard the one
that we're going to hear about tonight
which is the question of the possible
role of central banks in in reducing the
risks of financial crises to talk to us
about this topic I think we couldn't
hope for a more authoritative speaker
than Jacques de la Rozier as many of you
already know mr. de la Rosa has had a
career of the highest distinction as a
civil servant in France he served for
many years at the French Treasury among
other capacities as the undersecretary
for monetary affairs and he continues to
chair the strategy committee of the
Treasury particularly relevant to the
topic of tonight's talk he served as the
governor of the Bank de France he's also
had many important roles in
international institutions including a
term as the President of the European
Bank for Reconstruction and Development
and a term as the managing director of
the International Monetary Fund mr.
Diller oza continues to serve on
high-level committees to many of those
really for me to list here I will
mention only one of his most recent
activities which was chairing the
high-level group on financial
supervision in the European Union this
committee presented an important report
to the EU last year recommending reforms
of the European fan
ential supervisory architecture and
earlier this fall the recommendations of
the dillo Rozier report were adopted by
the European Parliament and the Council
of Ministers so they now form the
framework that will guide financial
regulation at the European level in
particular it was this report that
proposed the creation of the new
European systemic risks Council that's
been established to collect and evaluate
information about risks to financial
stability at the European level and also
the creation of the new European system
of financial supervisors which will
oversee and coordinate the work of the
various national financial supervisory
agencies so I think it's mostly a
tribute to the efforts of Jacques de la
rose' that Europe is now ahead of the
United States in developing new
regulatory structures to deal with the
problem of systemic risk in the world
financial system which have been so
glaringly exposed by the recent crisis
but he's not been content to rest on his
laurels with this achievement and he's
now turned his attention to the
reconsideration of the role of central
banks in the light of the crisis I'm
sure we'll all be very interested to
hear his reflections so I'm very pleased
to prevent to you Jacques de la Rosa
good evening ladies and gentlemen I am
delighted and very honored to be in such
in such a wonderful hall with you at
Columbia University which reputation is
is great i must say in my own country i
would like to thank professor de menil
who has been the initiator of my coming
tonight and who has devoted a lot of
attention and kindness to my to my visit
here and also professor Mike Woodford
for the very kind words that he has just
said the the subject is monetary policy
has played a major role in the run-up to
the financial crisis when I arrived in
the United States two days ago I passed
the immigration procedures and the
immigration officer asked me the ritual
question why are you visiting the United
States and I said because I'm on a
business trip he looked at me and
probably he felt that you know it was a
bit odd that i was doing business so he
said what type of business are you doing
well i said i maxed other things i'm
going to give a lecture at columbia
university and he said may I ask on what
subject and I said on monetary policy he
looked at me plank he said what monetary
policy I said yes interest rates credit
oh he said well you can tell them that
we made a big mess of it
and I said well in a nutshell that's
exactly what I'm going to try to
demonstrate now the thesis that I will
present to you today draws from an
article that I published in central
banking at the beginning of 2010 it was
the result of reflections and work that
I had embarked upon several years ago at
the time the article received no
reaction but over the last 10 years or
so a number of economists have been
writing on the subject and central
bankers have lately started to pay
attention to the linkages between
monetary policy and asset bubbles
furthermore the recent creation in
Europe and in the United States of
systemic risks boards or councils
entails for central bankers the duty to
analyze an ongoing fashion macroeconomic
and financial risks and to make
recommendations including on monetary
policy matters in order to prevent the
recurrence of crises like the one we
have been living through and that has
had so dramatic negative consequences in
terms of growth employment and fiscal
policies a number of central bankers and
their economic advisors tend to consider
that monetary policy played little or no
significant role in the run-up to the
crisis on this view the financial
upheaval was mainly the result of an
external macroeconomic shock made worse
by the important behavior of some
financial institutions the argument can
be summarized and some extent simplified
as follows inflation measured by CPI
index has been low and stable over the
years
therefore the fundamental objective of
monetary policy which is price stability
has been achieved secondly the financial
crisis was basically the result of
excess savings and balance of payment
surplus of major emerging economies who
pegged their currencies more or less on
the dollar this caused the surge in
housing and other asset prices and it
enabled the u.s. current account deficit
to be financed this excess liquidity
created by these imbalances was not
caused by monetary policy they say and
lastly another factor that explains the
crisis is the behavior of a number of
financial institutions in particular non
banks hedge funds investment banks that
went too far in leveraging their capital
now I believe this argument is seriously
misleading and that the explosion of
credit which is in essence a monetary
phenomenon was a major factor not to say
the major factor behind the crisis for
example the ratio of us private sector
debt to GDP skyrocketed from 112 percent
in 1976 to two hundred and ninety
percent ninety-five percent in 2008 in
Britain the ratio of households mortgage
debt to disposable income has surged
from eighty percent in 91 this is the
stock of debt to one hundred and forty
percent in 2008 in the United States
credit expanded by around ten to fifteen
percent per year from two thousand four
to two thousand eight when economic
growth in nominal terms was around five
percent and in Europe you had similar
things with eight to ten percent annual
increase in credit for nominal GDP
growth of less than four percent
this explosion of debt was bound to have
monetary consequences loans kade
deposits as the textbooks used to
teachers the fact that many central
banks and in particular the Federal
Reserve which allowed real interest
rates to have around zero for several
years pushed up credit expansion which
in turn impacted monitor on the monetary
aggregates is not debatable on the
external front we know from the research
done by Jacques Barack in the 60s that
it is the evolution of net domestic
assets which is credit to the economy
into the public sector there is the main
determinants of current account
imbalances and the variations of those
imbalances so given the importance of
credit for both domestic and external
monetary stability it is something of a
mystery to me at least that central
banks don't seem to have paid much
attention to it as an indicator even
though traditionally credit growth has
been a major element in the analysis and
toolbox of monetary policymakers at the
very least the magnitude of the credit
bubble should have raised questions
about the adequacy of monetary policies
central bankers response to the view
that I have just expressed goes
something like this as inflation
measured by Consumer Price Index remain
subdued it would have been irresponsible
for central bankers to tighten their
policies and increase interest rates
that the risk of curtailing economic
growth and increasing unemployment
that's the way the argument goes
but the the implication of that argument
would be to limit the operation of
monetary policy to the achievement of a
strict concept of inflation targeting
prices of goods and services or of a
non-inflationary potential growth
targeting as was the case in the United
States now after the crisis has struck
and left massive casualties in its wake
you just have to remember that in the
u.s. shift of gdp growth between two
0729 has been minus 4.5 percent and they
have reached close to ten percent
unemployment now even the most convinced
defenders of central bank's past
policies should in my view concede that
it would have been appropriate to
monitor the credit indicators more
closely and act upon them in any case
they start agreeing on the proposal for
a systemic risk council which is to
avoid a repetition of past experience
some even tend to agree that if
regulatory instruments prove
insufficient monetary policy could be
used as a supplementary tool in case of
excessive credit expansion at this point
of the analysis I would like to stress
five of the monetary quote-unquote
aspects of the credit bubble firstly the
expansion of credit which fuelled
domestic demand was a powerful
contributor to the increase in asset
prices furthermore high asset prices
produce wealth effects which in turn
feed into the credit bubble richer you
believe you are the more you are tempted
to borrow especially when the banking
sector as it was particularly the case
in the US and in Britain is able to
quote unquote extract value from izing
housing prices strong risk appetite in
an environment of low interest rates led
to a deterioration of risk quality to a
weakening of due diligence and to very
thin spreads further the adoption of
mark-to-market accounting compounded the
surge in asset prices and its wealth
effects since quote-unquote paper
profits and valuations increased in good
times and gave the impression that
collateral was plentiful and of good
quality secondly low US interest rates
which were even negative in real terms
from late two thousand two two mid-2005
given the inflationary expectations
generated a perverse process lower rates
the more risk was taken therefore the
probability of a crisis increased the
crisis when it bug out required in turn
low interest rates to preserve the
financial system this has been called
the low interest rate trap thirdly the
systemic pegging to the US dollar of a
number of currencies of structural
surplus countries like China but also
Middle Eastern countries and others
entailed a significant increase in
liquidity and has resulted in lower
interest rates no one could deny that
intervention on the foreign exchange
markets is a monetary policy decision
the International Monetary Fund and its
shareholders have allowed the massive
accumulation of excess
dollar-denominated reserves by surplus
countries
thus condoning in a way the consequent
surge in international liquidity
fourthly the regulation and financial
innovation have allowed financial
institutions particularly investment
banks hedge funds to increase their
leverage the abuse of off-balance sheet
operations like special investment
vehicles conduits etc and of
securitization of complex and often
opaque products significantly
contributed to the expansion of credit
for a given amount of regulatory capital
these institutions could indeed lend
much more by accelerating what I call
the rotation of their own funds and
getting off their balance sheets the
loans they had extended to their clients
the conjunction of an easy monetary
policy and weak regulation favored the
expansion of financial products like
adjusted paid mortgage which with rates
indexed on short-term low interest rates
this considerably increased the
transmission channel of monetary policy
and contributed to the crisis and lastly
credit bubbles like the housing bubble
room that the u.s. experienced them in
the 2000s can be much more detrimental
than the bubbles that are not financed
with debt such as the Internet bubble
the banking system had come to rely
increasingly on wholesale funding and on
the shadow banks which could increase
their leverage without regulatory
constraints as a result the large part
of the credit bubble was financed on a
very short-term basis essentially
overnight collateralized loans as long
as asset prices we're up firms could
easily ball given the higher value of
their
but this increase of borrowing in
bowling led to overcapacity in the
economy which eventually resulted later
in a sharp downturn when the cycle
reversed the loss spiral hadn't had
enormous amplification effects indeed
investors as soon as the value of their
assets tumbled saw their net worth
collapse and hence their ability to
borrow dwindle they were left with one
alternative ie reduced their positions
by selling assets when prices were
falling to make things worse margin
calls and haircuts started hurting
investors when asset prices declined and
forced them to sell which in turn
depressed assets further and increased
margin calls one can understand given
the high leverage of us investment banks
in particular how much the financial
system got into debt if you look for
instance at the figures in the United
States from 78 to 2008 the net debt of
financial institutions related to GDP
sword from sixteen percent to 121
percent you don't you can't understand
the crisis if you don't have those types
of figures in mind the financial system
allied very heavily on boring thus the
terrible consequences resulting from the
vicious cycle that I have just described
can one reasonably argue that the five
monetary issues that i have just
analyzed and i only took five have
nothing to do with monetary policy and
with the responsibility of central banks
i leave that question to you when
liquidity and credit surge in an
environment of low interest rates while
the Consumer Price Index remain stable
in large part because of the low wage
costs associated with imports from
emerging countries perhaps more than
from the wisdom central banks and as
exchange rate flexibility can no longer
play its role as a safety valve the only
outlet is the increase in price in asset
prices the bubbles were a natural
accompaniment of low interest rates and
of what I think was an inappropriate and
asymmetric monetary stance indeed
monetary policy was eased to avoid a
downturn with far greater speed and
decisiveness then we are displayed
during periods or gradualist tightening
when the economy was overheating this
asymmetry was an invitation to moral
hazard since it created the expectations
that central banks would take a medial
policy action if asset prices we're a
fall one illustration of this asymmetric
approach to monetary policy is the
liquidity injection by the Fed to
prevent a feared but mistaken
deflationary threat in 2002 his
overreaction produced a massive bubble
now I come to my second and last section
of this little talk to avoid the
repetition of such events central banks
in my view will have to start again
monitoring the expansion of credit and
therefore to get interested in bubbles
the objective the objection is the
objective is certainly not to target
asset prices like you can target
inflation measured by consumer price
indexes
central banks cannot of course determine
the white value of assets this targeting
quote unquote objective is often
presented by those who defend the
central bank's status quo as if it were
the alternative solution this of course
is in part aimed to discredit the idea
that we need central banks to react
sufficiently early on to emerging
bubbles the objection is often that
central bankers are not in a position
and lower is to identify a bubble this
seems to me to be a particularly weak
argument you did not need to determine
scientifically the right quote unquote
value for example of houses in the
United States in 2005 to know that there
was an excessive rise in prices actually
everybody knew it we certainly knew it
better than we could forecast inflation
or output gaps which are considered as
normal judgments to be made by central
bankers the national bureau of economic
research has recently published a paper
that shows how i quote a rising home
prices falling mortgage rates and more
efficient refinancing ruled masses of
home owners to refinance their homes and
extract equity at the same time
increasing systemic risk in the
financial system end of code this very
illuminating paper shows that home
equity extractions alone can account for
the dramatic increase in systemic risk
posed by the u.s. residential market
which was the epicenter of the financial
crisis of 2007-2010
eight now what central banks should do
and such ominous circumstances should
they remain inactive wait for the burst
and then mop up the mess my reef
lighting on the contrary I believe that
they should lean against the wind and
that they can use different policy
options to that effect they should in my
view lean against the wing to improve
macroeconomic performance by reacting
systematically to asset price
misalignments over and above their
reaction to inflation forecast and
output gaps the reason for this view is
that asset price bubbles create
distortions in investment consumption
and inflation thus leading to excessive
quote-unquote increases and then to
severe falls in both real output and
inflation monetary policy can smooth in
my view and moderate these excesses and
fluctuations through interest rate
actions my view is that a central bank
would achieve a better performance if it
encompassed in its inflation targeting
process the evolution of asset prices
and not only CPI inflation and output
gaps now this does not mean that we
should put a arithmetic figure to the
increase in asset prices that can be
concerning but it means that when you
make your judgments in terms of monetary
policy you have to have in mind these
trends one should have in mind that the
cost of bubbles can be very high the IMF
for instance has estimated on the basis
of past experience that housing busts
take on average five years to get
normalized
in are associated with output losses
that can reach over the period something
like eight percent of GDP since asset
price variation do impact inflation and
in a way are the reflection of
inflationary expectations and given that
central bank's objective is to limit
inflation why shouldn't they take into
account asset price inflation in their
policy tools they can use central
bankers different policy options they
can adopt to less accommodative monetary
policy this can provide the market I
think the right signals make more
credible the anti inflationary stance in
its most comprehensive definition and
thus help to anchor future price
expectations if the market new ex ante
that monetary policy will react to
emerging asset price bubbles that might
reduce the possibility of bubbles they
can also adopt regulatory measures to
motivate credit expansion either in
general or in specific sectors like
setting dynamic provisioning increasing
reserve obligations setting more
stringent rules regarding loan-to-value
ratios and things of the like these
could be used either as an alternative
to tightening monetary policy or a
supplement to it some might object that
increasing interest rates for instance
is too blunt an instrument to prevent a
bubble from bursting and that regulatory
measures are not always within the
competence of central banks these
arguments in my view are not convincing
interest rates should be used when
needed to lean against the wind and
regulatory measures should be promoted
by central banks if they are required to
prevent financial instability this is
why the report on the form of the
European supervisory system which you
are kind enough to allude to
has proposed the creation of a systemic
risk board grouping the european central
bankers and supervisors in order to
detect early enough systemic risks and
to propose precise measures including
regulatory measures to deal with them
lastly some may argue that if central
banks were responsible not only to for
price stability but also for financial
stability this could entail conflicts
between the two objectives and could
weaken their main mission which is price
stability or even their independence I
believe in the light of what has
happened over the last two years that
this is not a convincing argument
firstly central banks have traditionally
been in charge of both both missions
price stability and financial stability
the practice of the last ten years
should not lead us to forget these basic
historic facts and professor Woodward
knows that perfectly furthermore a
number of central banks are in charge of
micro supervision of banks so and
secondly bestowing on central banks and
regulators the responsibility of acting
to prevent financial crises in my view
can only strengthen their authority and
independence and lastly let us consider
the monetary consequences of not acting
to prevent bubbles we have seen the
wealth effect effects of asset prices
and the consequences of excessive credit
expansion they have by themselves
contributed to over capacity to output
volatility and eventually undermine the
foundations of a stable financial system
the ongoing deleveraging process will
have major negative economic
consequences especially in the most
indebted econ
is private and public like in the US and
the UK would it not have been wiser to
tighten early Earth which no doubt would
have entailed some pain rather than let
the enormous credit bubble expand and
burst thus resulting in a deep recession
and in a surge in unemployment which
seems in commensurate with what would
have happened under the hypothesis of an
earlier tightening once asset prices
started to fall the whole financial
sector almost collapsed enormous
injections of central bank liquidity
short and medium-term and of public
support where needed we see how
difficult it is for central banks to
start thinking of an exit strategy is
that massive intervention and
quantitative easing policy consistent in
the longer run with monetary stability
some fear that inflation will come back
when the huge liquidity created finds
its way into the financing of the real
economy some others believe that the
present degree of slack points more
towards the risk of deflation the fact
that these expectations are so different
poses a new challenge to central banks
and to their credibility in leading to
stabilizing expectations all in all
there seems to me little doubt that
monetary policy contributed
significantly to the emergence of the
crisis thus time has come to question
the monetary policy operational model
that has prevailed over the last 10 to
15 years it's basic principles have been
tested throughout the crisis and have
not in my view withstood the
test it is somewhat paradoxical that in
a world of increasing financial
complexity central banks have tended to
oversimplify their operational policy
one single and narrowly defined
objective has prevailed with some
limited variations CPI Consumer Price
Index targeting one single policy tool
has dominated the use a symmetric of
official interest rates and the blind
eye has been turned by most to credit
expansion and to the surge in asset
prices actually extracting value from
high asset prices has become if you
think at it a main instrument for some
important policy makers and politicians
to sustain growth we have seen the
dangers that is the destruction of value
and the generalized accession of such
artificial methods of promoting growth I
would also underline that this so-called
consensus on monetary policy is rather
recent as I said and that the history of
central banking which you know more than
anyone provides a host of more
comprehensive objectives and operational
tools in this regard one can observe
that inflation targeting as it has been
practiced was based on what 2 to 3-year
CPI forecasting this short term horizon
resulted in giving an insufficient
waiting to price misalignments which are
at the root of asset bubbles but we'd
have which have to be considered on a
lawyer term horizon contrary to the
so-called consensus and trying to avoid
any dogmatic approach I consider that
financial stability should be part and
parcel of the objecting of promoting
stable monetary
conditions asset bubbles can be
recognized and eventually acted upon by
central banks credit expansion should be
closely monitored and moderated when
needed when action is to be taken the
earlier the better actions and tools
should be multifaceted interest rate
preserves changes in regulations etc in
this regard I repeat that loan-to-value
ratios are very powerful tools to
prevent excessive credit expansion
without hindering the economy with too
high interest rates anchoring
inflationary expectations on a long-term
horizon is crucial and introducing an
anti cyclical dimension in monetary
policy like dynamic provisioning in good
days to be run down in bad ones is also
a useful method nothing of all this
would or should lead to a weakening of
central bank's independence on the
contrary providing central banks with a
more comprehensive lida find stability
mandate could only in my view enhance
their credibility I come to the end of
my presentation you have understood that
the theme that underlines this analysis
is that financial institutions play a
fundamental role in the transmission
mechanisms of monetary policy not a big
discovery however monetary policy makers
we're not i think well prepare prepared
either analytically operationally to
prevent or model the excesses of credit
expansion that eventually bought the
system down large number of banks with
the prevailing anglo-saxon originate and
distribute model we're providing
investors with a park and sometimes very
poorly understood financial products
whose rating by credit agencies
we're meaningless this supply of complex
financial products was met by an
ever-growing demand of investors whose
liquidity was plentiful in particular
because of massive international
imbalances and no interest rates through
the securitisation process banks could
as I say he used their capital to
originate and distribute again and again
very low interest rates had therefore
much stronger transmission effect than
in the past when global imbalances
securitisation of complex products
financial globalization and the
existence of a vast shadow banking
system where non-existent or much lesser
the consequences were with hindsight
inevitable the more liquidity was
abundant the easier was the short-term
funding to interbank commercial bank
paper markets etc for institutions like
banks mutual funds pension funds hedge
funds and engaged in investing in these
complex financial products the tide was
arrested irresistibly mounting while
central bankers were continuing to focus
on CPI inflation which was okay it is
noteworthy that economists had studied
with care and precision the dangers of
the credit channel into Great Depression
years they had rightly pointed out that
banks could be major transmitters and
shapers if I could say so of monetary
policies banks indeed could tighten
their loans because of upcoming defaults
because of high credit risk of borrowers
and therefore because the cost of
capital was high why then why then
didn't those same economist pay more
attention during the boom
to the reverse but symmetrical risks
involved in the behavior of financial
institutions their profits were
artificially inflated by accounting
standards their leverage and risk
appetite were high in a context of low
interest rates and concerns on the
credit risks of borrowers were reduced
as securitisation was supposed to spread
the risk around the credit transmission
channel was in fact much more powerful
than assume indeed it was paralleled and
compounded by the increasing leverage of
certain financial institutions like
investment banks in the United States
hedge funds that behaved as banks
transforming short-term market funding
into longer-term acids but we are not
subject to a stringent regulation as
banks where the result was an enormous
regulatory arbitrage towards hedge funds
off-balance-sheet vehicles save
sponsored by banks but in theory
independently managed as the parallel
shadow banking system these parallel
banks turned out to be accelerators of
credit expansion and consequently
contributed to loosen monetary
conditions most of them at little
capital and were over leveraged the
collateral they provided to their
lenders was in many cases of dubious
care quality CDOs were often accepted
now when the markets eventually
understood that real estate prices were
coming down the whole structure crumbled
the shameful practice of granting
subprime mortgage to borrowers who were
known by brokers and banks as well as my
supervisors as unable to service their
loan became public
the financial products based on subprime
mortgages products that have been
granted triple-a ratings by inept rating
agencies suddenly we're seen as what
they were there is worthless banks and
hedge funds suddenly lost their
short-term funding and many did not have
either the Capitol or the liquidity to
survive those banks which had been
imprudent had to be rescued at a great
cost for taxpayers and hedge funds were
severely hit while they compounded till
the sale of their assets the fall in
markets securitisation almost
disappeared far from constituting an
institutional buffer against falling
markets as they often had in the past
financial institutions had become so
dependent on financial markets that they
were the first to be impacted by the
fall in assets and to exacerbate the
market downturn no more buffers thus the
old- channel reappeared as in the 30s
that no one had really struck the alarm
bell in the years of over extension what
explains this asymmetry is it the Great
Moderation in inflation which is not
well analyzed is it the illusion that
markets will never fail is it the
obsession of deflation that appeared in
this country a few years ago is it
because of the implicit belief that
cycles had disappeared and that
productivity gains would ensure forever
hi and non-inflationary potential growth
I leave you the answers the least one
can say is that the Great Recession with
its millions of unemployed its thousands
of billions of bailouts its spectacular
rise and deterioration of central banks
balance sheets cannot be lightly
discarded as the result of some
external accidents or excessive savings
in some parts of the world tough
questions have to be answered by
policymakers government's central banks
regulators supervisors as well as by
financial institutions it is essential
that they address the real causes of the
crisis which I think are major
international imbalances inadequate
monetary policy in the context of asset
bubbles insufficient professionalism
supervisors procyclical t of prudential
and regulatory rules accounting in
sufficient liquidity during the crisis
excessive leverage of major investment
banks and of hedge funds poor governance
often leading to hurt behaviors
short-term biases and incentives and
that central banks get really involved
in financial stability so that the huge
and I think unacceptable moral hazard
problem that has plagued the world does
not happen again are the present efforts
to reform the regulatory system adequate
this is another subject which I will not
deal with I think they are certainly in
many respects a step forward in the
right direction but the emphasis on
increasing capital buffers in the
banking systems seems to me somewhat
misplaced insurance efficient capital
was not by far the major cause of the
crisis liquidity was the real problems
and it must be addressed in a coherent
way without jeopardizing the vital
intermediation and transformation
function of the banking system more
attention should be devoted to the
quality of supervision and to the likely
expansion of the shadow banking system
that will no doubt take advantage of the
increasing capital constraints of the
regulatory bank and regulated banks and
without a comprehensive international
macroeconomic surveillance
imbalances will continue to flourish in
this respect macro-prudential oversight
should play its full role in warning
governments and markets about nascent
deviations or bubbles let us hope they
will fulfill their mission with
independence competence and forcefulness
thank you very much for your attention
now if you want to ask questions I would
be delighted to take some
so we will have some time for some
questions and there's a microphone over
there is that the only microphone period
is that there's yes that okay there's
microphones on the two sides before
anyone who wants to ask the question can
go to one of the microphones before you
do I would like to comment that mr. de
la Rosa's remarks in response to the
questions will be off the record I don't
know if they're members of the press
here or not but if there are his
responses to the questions will be off
the record and if he says something
interesting you should seek him out
afterwards to ask if he's willing to say
something on the record or not the the
other piece of advice I had was that
questioners should give your name and
your affiliation before before you're
asking you a question so we have a first
question as any central banker in five
been fired as any central banker been
fired no I don't think so
why not because because the policies of
the policies are what I said I mean
everybody sort of accepted this
framework and you know that was it so
the analysis that I have presented was
not you didn't you didn't find it very
easily there were some economies that
were making those points but you know
there's no nothing wrong don't hesitate
to ask indiscreet questions because as
Churchill said questions are never in
discreet it's the answers that can be so
I'll have to I'll happen to motivate
give us a question here yes I was
wondering if you could make some
comments on what's been rumored today
about the easing in Europe possible
easing in Europe quantitative easing
that might take place and being done
through the IMF essentially after we've
just had a quantitative easy here how do
you see all this liquid e that's being
created where will it finally end up yes
thank you very much this is exactly the
type of questions that I would like to
avoid because you are asking me to make
a judgment or an assessment of a
monetary policy stance which has not yet
been defined if I am well informed and
therefore I will not comment if you have
in mind something else which is the
Sunday arrangement between the Europe
eurozone countries I am ready to make a
few comments on that but but this is
perhaps not your question if your
question is strictly monetary
quantitative monetary easing I I have to
skip that one
but if you're interested in in the
package euro package of last Sunday I
can I could say a few words are you okay
well i think the the sunday package is
is very interesting i was traveling that
day so i have no particular insights in
all that but what I read made me think
that three things that happened which
were positive the first thing is that
this european fund or financial
mechanism is going to be made permanent
and we're not will not lapse in 2013 now
that's very important because there was
an uncertainty in a large segment of the
market on the on what would happen after
2013 the second point which i think is
very interesting is that if after 2013 a
sovereign of the of the zone is under
debt pressure there will be a systematic
intervention by the IMF and the European
financial mechanisms in order to
determine what has to be done and the
third thing which i think is very
interesting is that it is understood
that if the judgment made collectively
is that there is an element of
unsustainability of the debt of the
sovereign in question there will then be
a mechanism that could lead at least 44
the subordinated holders of death all
the holders of subordinated debt could
lead to to a restructuring that is a
contribution by those
letters to the financial package so I
think these are three important
initiatives that have been taken and in
my mind they should greatly contribute
to the stabilization of the of the user
and that's the way I would put it but I
am ready to take other other questions
if you will give a question on the other
side of the room here yes yes I'm I'm
going to ask you about a counter fact
she say who you are and on your
affiliation sorry Bernadette Kilroy I'm
in the financial industry you said that
because there was not a completely
freely floating set of exchange rates in
the world and there was pegging by large
emerging economies including also
economies in the Middle East if that had
not been the case and I know it really
as I'm asking a counterfactual but if it
had not been the case how severe with
the crisis have been could you could you
sensitize that because I if the
countries that you refer to had not been
pegging their exchange rates to the
dollar how much would that have affected
the severity of the crisis well it's
it's difficult to to answer that
question because I have not studied in a
quantitative way what would have
happened always difficult to to evaluate
that but my feeling is that if the
exchange rate had shown more flexibility
as it as it ought to you would have had
by definition less accumulation of
reserves in those countries less
intervention which are the an act of
creating liquidity and therefore that
there would have been less liquidity
around and perhaps higher ambulant if I
could put it that way interest rates so
I think there is an element here now
should monetary policy take as a given
that you know that's the way it
functions people peg and personally I
don't think so I think
a proper functioning of an international
monetary system is not consistent with
with a very large structural i would say
countries either on the on the creditor
side on the surplus side or not to
accumulate sort of unlimited reserves or
debts i think the system should be
overhauled so that it functions in a
more symmetric way it's easy to say it
is more difficult to do there are some
ideas on how to improve the functioning
of the exchange rate system all the
balance of payment system you could
imagine recalls to quantitative
indicators American Treasury proposed
some caps on surfaces or deficits they
had proposed in the 70s another another
idea which was there a country that
accumulated systemic increases in
reserves or increases indebtedness would
have after a certain point to be under
under the the i would say surveillance
of the IMF that could then be entitled
to look into the policy mix of the
country things like that the more you
you see the functioning or the
dysfunctioning of the system as I tried
to show it the moment you are inclined
to look into these issues with sense of
innovation and responsibility I don't
think we can continue to cling to these
methods of
you know doing what you want Alec after
I think the system is more is too
interconnected today to allow these
things now it doesn't mean that some
countries are going to have to e value
their currencies it means that the
policy mix that leads to continuous
imbalances be they on the plus side of
the minus side have to be have to be
your viewed and there has to be an
element of automaticity in this review
if you wanted to bite so in all my life
I never managed get that done but I hope
that situation being worse now maybe
something will come out of all these
dogs okay another question over here yes
Jana silly guy kiss from the henry
george school i have one comment first
of all it seems to me that economists
have no idea what money is and that's a
big problem with with the current
economic crisis man is just an indicator
of wealth okay so it seems to me that
american economists have it all wrong
because they expand the money the
monetary supply when the economic has
contracted so it means that the wealth
of the country has contracted yet they
increase the money supply on the other
hand Europe seems to have a more correct
no understanding of what money is and
instead of expanding the money supply
they put their economies into recession
too to counter this economic contraction
so I would like you to comment on that
and another question is it seems to me
that the this current crisis has
resulted because we shifted wealth from
the productive factors of the economy
that's labor and capital into land which
is unproductive what would you think of
this measure which
+ tax wages and capital and tax heavily
land values as a way out of the crisis
thank you very much yeah well I mean
there's a lot of controversial things in
what you you said first of all the
comparison between Europe that chooses a
recession in order not to expand its
money supply and in the u.s. excessive
money supply I think things are more
nuanced than that there has been a very
active increase in the balance sheet of
the ECB not as large as what happened
with the Fed but there has been great
contribution of the ECB to the liquidity
of the financial system in Europe so
it's more question of degree and it's
the quantitative easing policy probably
that you have in mind and that is indeed
to some extent different in its
orientation but things are not exactly
as as different as you may characterize
them now when you say that it would be
better to tax very heavily the real
estate if I understood you well or
acquisition of houses and and and reduce
the taxation on on labor and production
I think that you you you have to
understand that the demand for housing
is not only as speculation it's also a
sort of social legitimate requests from
people who want to to have a roof over
their heads and to overtax the
acquisition of property in the in the
housing sector is not necessarily the
best way to do it there are other real
if I may say so assets like gold or
other other financial instruments that
that could also be in your in your tax
targeting so I think I wouldn't I
wouldn't buy that as you as you
presented it I think it's a little more
bit more complex which what I think
fundamentally is that you you the system
must not put acquirers of houses a at
risk that is my thesis i think it is
dangerous to overdo the the lending the
landing site in the u.s. you have a
system whereby the house is the is in a
way the guarantee of the loan in Europe
it is a different system the banks lend
to mortgage candidates not on the house
with a course on on all
of revenues and assets that the
individuals have that is a very
disciplinarian method much more than
just keep lending against a house
because the the borrower has to make
calculations on not on the value of its
house of his house or her house but on
the future of its income and and banks
have to make a very careful assessment
of what the repay ability if I could put
it that way of the loan is whilst when
you think that you've got a good good
collateral with the house when your bank
well you're exposed to the risk of
falling prices which we we have now in
in your country so i think the the way
you do it and also the the buying
systematically of mortgages by gses like
Fannie Mae or Freddie Mac is something
that we we don't know in Europe there is
no father Christmas to to buy bank's
loans in terms of mortgages they have to
keep them on their books so it makes
them perhaps more prudent and so I think
it's those things more than banging
people on the head with taxes that is
important I mean we can take another
question from the other side thank you
my name is Chris I'm a graduate student
here in economic policy my question is
one of economic governance in regard to
an international reserve currency you
spoke briefly on global imbalances in
particular we've seen that the US dollar
as a standard reserve currency is
dependent on the u.s. continuing to run
a deficit do you have any opinion or
discussion on using special drawing
rights as an international reserve
currency and if so would that be under
the domain
the IMF perhaps yes I thank you for your
question I think indeed the system is
now very dependent in terms of the
providing liquidity to the system is
very is very dependent on the deficits
of the United States in a way now it's
not absolutely indispensable to have a
balance of payments deficit when you are
a reserve currency there have been
examples in the 19th century in the
beginning of the 20th century when the
United Kingdom was with the pound the
the main reserve currency didn't have
balance of payments deficits it had
actually surpluses in its current
account of its trade account but it
exported out the long-term capital which
of course balance the the situation and
it would be an ideal situation if I were
American i would say that to have the US
dollar as the indeed the International
Monetary currency which it is but to
have it without these these very
problematic continuous deficits but okay
it's not doable now now the SDR question
is is I think very it's a very good
question because if you do really
overhaul the functioning of the system I
think you have to ask the question
wouldn't it be better to have an
international currency issued by an
international organization or central
bank which the IMF could could be the
the prefiguration of which would issue
a international currency like the
Special Drawing rights now you have to
understand that the Special Drawing
rights is only the mirror of the major
currencies in the world that is the
United States dollar you are the pound
swiss franc i mean that's basically what
what the SDR is so if you want to have a
stabilization in the system you have to
have a discipline amongst the countries
which featured the SDR certain form of
discipline because if they if they have
two large variations against each other
then in a way you replicate the errata
Scism of the present system so you have
to have an element of convergence which
brings you back to what I said in terms
of the surveillance of the international
monetary system imbalances and all that
if you had that yes the SDR would be a
way to provide liquidity if you had a
need liquidity in the system presently I
don't think you have a need of liquidity
you probably have too much liquidity but
it could be that one day you would have
a need and then the SDR would fulfill
its function the one that was bestowed
on it at the very beginning and which
was never really carried out because
when I was managing director of the IMF
for nine years nine times each year
religiously i went to the board and i
said we my the economist of the whole
search department have determined that
there was some what did we call it
scarcity in some there was a word sacred
word in liquidity there was a need for
more liquidity and nine times i was
turned
by all the disciplinarians of the board
which said no no there's abundant
liquidity it's badly distributed but
it's abundant so no way that we will
create SD oz now with the g20 has
managed to make a creation of SDR two
years ago which i think is is an
interesting step forward but it's still
very small in terms of them of the SDR
and the total liquidity it must be solid
four or five percent so it's not making
a dent but you know we never know the
Queen take one more question for this
mark melaka columbia university thank
you very much for the comprehensive
analysis i have a very short question
always wanted to ask an central banker
did you foresee the crisis if so when
and why and how did you act upon well
this is a good question i'm on the way
record on this i will send you if you
will my statements that i made in
2004-2005 yes I did say publicly that
the brilliance of the housing market in
the US was a sign of a what I called
systemic crisis I was immediately
corrected negatively by some very high
personalities of the monetary world and
I shut up but things happen so you know
I'm not boasting about that is there's
nothing I think it's in a way the guy
who saw me at the at the customs the day
before yesterday was perfectly aware of
these things and was a collective
misjudgment thank you very much I much
appreciated your questions and I hope I
didn't bore you too much thank you thank
you
setting very good questions okay so we
we will move on